we're delighted to be here tonight of
course I'm very excited I don't want to
embarrass Donald but you see really some
of my happiest days when we were
together at MGM Oh Debbie you didn't
have to say that I would have said it no
no come on now you remember the number
we did together abbadabba honeymoons
remember that oh yes I was going under
the name of Carlton carpenter at the
time you're taller guys Runkle oh yeah
no you forget now wait had another three
little words we did the number in there
no Debbie no no you goofed again that's
yes oh yes that was another dancer he
dances a little bit better than I do
Fred Astaire yeah well then it was
singing in the rain
I remember that you would in the rain
and dancing around they had umbrella
remember in the street with the water
going everywhere
well that's yes now you've got it I've
got it now you're gonna make em laugh me
no that's tellin but anyway the
nominations now now what did we say do
you remember oh yes you want to read
that nominations are yes for original
song score mm-hmm Jesus Christ Superstar
adapted by Andre Previn Herbert Spencer
Andrew Lloyd Webber your sting adopted
by Marvin Hamlisch Tom Sawyer song score
by Richard M Sherman and Robert B
Sherman adapted by John Williams may I
have the envelope please
there you are Debbie like the envelope
the winner is
Marvin Hamlisch for the stage
I'm very happy and I really wanted this
first of all I am really thrilled that
my parents could be here to see this and
I'm happy that I'm still alive because
I've been sitting there a long time
first of all a big thank you to Michael
and Julia Phillips and Tony bill but I
really have to share this award
so I'll give I'll give George Roy hill
some visiting rights to see this he is
not only a brilliant director but he's a
wonderful musician and he he really
helped so so much and of course too man
I never met but his music was just
wonderful to work with to Scott Joplin
thank you all
now to help present the next award is
our conductor three-time Oscar winner
Henry Mancini accompanied by the one and
only non Perrine incomparable Cher
Best Original dramatic score our John
Williams for Cinderella liberty George
Delarue for the day of the dolphin Jerry
Goldsmith for Pepe Young John Cameron
for a touch of class and Marvin Hamlisch
for we were who Hamlisch mich Hamlisch
sorry about that Marvin the envelope
please
what do you think Marvin come back
sure sure up right huh what can I tell
you my piano teacher is thrilled about
this I know she kept saying practice to
Turay stark Sydney [ __ ]
- Barbra Streisand a big a big big thank
you I can say that right off the bat
there were there were a lot of people
involved in the music of this and I'm
glad I was one of them and I can only
tell you last but not least I want to
thank them the makers of maalox for
making this all possible